la dernière fois on a vu comment les
informaticiens va cliquer sheridan qui
ont su formaliser le concept de
complexité d'une explication à travers
la notion de dimension wc et on avait vu
que la dimension wc permettait de
formaliser la notion intuitive que si la
complexité d'une explication est une
petite fraction du nombre de données
alors la généralisation de l'explication
a détonné non observé ne sera pas trop
mauvaise aujourd'hui on va pousser cette
notion un peu plus loin en parlant du
théorème fondamental de l'apprentissage
statistiques ce théorème dit la chose
suivante si la dimension bce n'est
qu'une petite fraction du nombre de
données d'apprentissage alors il n'y
aura pas trop de risque de trop grande
sur interprétations donc en gros ça dit
à peu près la même chose que les thermes
de vals nick deux épisodes précédents
mais j'ai choisi deux camps même vous
parlez du thaurac fondamental de
l'apprentissage statistiques parce qu'il
est souvent considéré comme un monument
de la théorie formelle du machine
learning et de son approche rigoureuse
et du coup je pense qu'on pourrait vous
reprocher de ne pas en avoir parlé mais
comme vous le sentez peut-être à ma voix
en fait je suis pas particulièrement fan
de ce théorème
enfin c'est clairement un magnifique
théorème mais je trouve qu'il ne mérite
pas vraiment son titre de fondamental
d'ailleurs à la fin de cette vidéo je
vous expliquerai pourquoi est-ce que je
pointe cela il se sera sans doute la
partie la plus intéressante de cette
vidéo
mais pour commencer il nous faut d'abord
comprendre ce théorème et sa
formalisation rigoureuse qui repose sur
une notion introduite par
l'informaticien leslie valiant tu cette
notion elle l'apprentissage probablement
approximativement correct apprentissage
pâques ou encore pack learning gagnante
remportera d'ailleurs le prix turing de
il ya un peu le prix nobel de
l'informatique en partie pour avoir
introduit la notion d'apprentissage
pâques mais aussi pour avoir introduit
toute une théorie de l'apprentissage de
façon intuitive l'apprentissage pack
formalise la notion de pas trop de
risque de trop grande sur
interprétations pour comprendre cela il
faut bien se rendre compte que le hasard
fait qu'il ya toujours un risque de
collecter des données qui ne sont
absolument pas représentative du
phénomène étudié
surtout si on ne connaît que peu de
données il ya toujours un risque que ces
données nous conduisent à mal à prendre
cependant plus on collecte de données
plus intuitivement la probabilité que
ces données soient représentatives sera
grande
c'est pour ça que même si on ne peut pas
entièrement exclure la possibilité
d'avoir des données non représentative
quand on connecte suffisamment de
données on peut néanmoins affirmer que
cette probabilité est faible
tout ce que j'ai décrit la correspond
qu'aux
à trop de risques dans la formulation
pas trop de risque de trop grande sur
interprétations et homo probablement
dans l'expression probablement
approximativement correct formellement
en a pris l'habitude de noter delta la
probabilité que les données donnent
vraiment n'importe quoi et on va
résonner avec le cas beaucoup plus
probable que ces données ne sont pas
trop n'importe quoi techniquement pour
les matheux parmi vous delta se
déterminent via les inégalités de
concentration comme les inégalités de
tirs 9 et correspond intuitivement à
retirer les que des destructions quasi
normal qu'ils sont des sommes d'un grand
nombre de variables indépendantes
ce genre d'astuce et vraiment
omniprésent en théorie du machine
learning
toutefois même si on a des données
représentatives il reste alors peu
probable que l'on arrive à déterminer
exactement la bonne explication des
données et en particulier si le chapeau
d'explication écran alors il ya peu de
chances que les données nous amène à
tirer la toute meilleure description qui
est dans le chapeau l'apprentissage
paquinou vide ne pas faire la fine
bouche et de nous satisfaire d'une
explication quasi optimale dans le sens
où le taux d'erreur de l'explication qui
a été sélectionné ne doit pas être
beaucoup plus grande que le taux
d'erreur de l'explication optimale
on utilise typiquement la lettre epson
pour mesurer l'écart entre l'explication
qui a été sélectionné et l'explication
optimale si le taux d'erreur de
l'explication qui a été sélectionnée est
un - d'epsilon du taux d'erreur de
l'explication optimale alors on dit que
l'apprentissage et epsilon correct on a
tout ce qu'il faut pour formaliser la
notion d'apprentissage probablement
approximativement correct on dit qu'un
apprentissage et epsilon delta pâques
si avec probabilité 1 - delta lorsque je
collecte l'étonné l'apprentissage va
conduire à la sélection d'une
explication qui et epsilon
approximativement correct littéralement
l'apprentissage sera un - delta
probablement epsilon approximativement
correct je peux maintenant annoncer la
version formal du théorème fondamental
de l'apprentissage statistiques ce
théorème dit que pour qu'un
apprentissage soit delta epsilon pas qu
il faut que le nombre de données
d'entraînement soit de l'ordre de wc
plus longue de 1 sur delta
le tout divisé par epsilon carré ou wc
et bien sûr la dimension wc du chapeau
d'explication ça c'est ce que beaucoup
appellent le théorème fondamental de
l'apprentissage statistiques
sachant qu'en pratique les logarithmes
joueur est négligeable ça veut dire que
comme le théorème de wernicke la firme
aussi pour éviter un trop grand risque
de trop grande sur interprétations il
faut que le nombre de données soit de
l'ordre de wc / ypsilon carré donc si je
prends une valeur de epson a ses petites
disons 0,1 ça veut dire qu'il faut
environ 100 fois plus de données que la
dimension wc de notre chapeau
d'explication ok donc ça que c'est un
peu l'application directe du théorème
mais je pense qu'ils aient aussi des
leçons philosophie qui a tiré de ce
théorème en particulier il me semble que
ce théorème indiquant quoi il est
souhaitable que les sciences ne cherche
pas à découvrir la vérité
oui parce qu'une vérité fondamentale
doit être en mesure d'expliquer toutes
les données or toute explication
parfaite des données est quasi certaine
de ne pas se généraliser comme
l'informatique théorique la statistique
nous invite à rejeter toute notion de
vérité fondamentale et a sans doute
davantage préféré le hashtag tous les
modèles sont faux certains sont utiles
autre enseignement important de ce
théorème on ne peut jamais être garantie
d'avoir évité la surinterprétation tant
qu'il y aura de la l'ead en automne et
il y aura toujours une probabilité que
l'apprentissage se passe mal même si
vous avez pris toutes vos précautions
dans la collecte de données en
particulier il me semble que prendre en
compte toute l'étendue de notre
ignorance soit une étape indispensable à
toute analyse de données et en
particulier que le langage des
probabilités soit indispensable à toute
philosophie du savoir ignorer les
probabilités en épistémologie c'est
négliger les probabilités pourtant
souvent non négligeable d'avoir des
données non représentative et toutes ces
conclusions font du théorème fondamental
de l'apprentissage statistiques un
théorème très intéressant mais il ya
quand même des bémols à mettre à toutes
ces interprétations du théorème
fondamental de l'apprentissage
statistiques
oui parce que ce théorème est beau mais
il a aussi ses limites et même beaucoup
de limites
pour commencer ce théorème est une
condition suffisante pour éviter à
surinterprétation ça veut dire qu'il
reste possible de ne pas être en régime
de surinterprétation quand bien même la
dimension wc du chapeau est bien plus
grande que le nombre de données
auxquelles on a accès comme le chercheur
en informatique jo farrington non pas
pour ce séminaire
ça semble d'ailleurs être le cas du
cerveau humain souvenez vous que l'on a
estimé la taille du cerveau à 10
puissance 15 pitt et donc sa dimension b
c est sans doute de l'ordre de 10
puissance 15 aussi alors même que ce
cerveau ne vit que 10 puissance 9
secondes
notre cerveau semble en fait
naturellement plus tôt dans un régime de
surinterprétation est alors oui en effet
souvent clairement on surinterprète mais
de là à dire que le cerveau humain sur
interprète tout le temps disons que
c'est très discutable et dans de futurs
épisodes on verra que la méthode
privilégiée des praticiens pour lutter
contre la surinterprétation ce n'est pas
de réduire la dimension wc de leurs
modèles
bref les théories fondamentales et joli
sur le papier mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il soit si pertinent en pratique une
deuxième faiblesse majeure du torrent
fondamentale ces kilos mais complètement
la surinterprétation par biais de
sélection dont on a pourtant parlé avec
hygiène mentale
en effet en pratique il arrive très
souvent que les deux années
d'apprentissage soit biaisée par rapport
aux données que l'algorithme rencontrera
en pratique typiquement les expériences
de psychologie sont souvent réalisés sur
des étudiants des universités
occidentales
tout bêtement parce que ce sont les
données qui sont accessibles aux
chercheurs en psychologie de même l'un
des plus grands problèmes de prédiction
et celui des résultats des élections à
partir de sondages
sauf que l'on sait que les sondages sont
des intentions de vote annoncé qu'ils
ont de bonnes chances d'être biaisés
vis-à-vis des votes à venir vouloir trop
collé aux données d'apprentissage sans
un modèle extérieur qui prend en compte
ses billets dans les données c'est
sauter à pieds joints dans le piège de
la surinterprétation et aboutir à une
conclusion qui se généralisera très mal
d'un point de vue théorique ce que je
critique la revient à critiquer le fait
que la distribution des données
d'apprentissage soit la même que la
distribution qui est utilisé pour juger
du fait que l'explication retenu est
bien epsilon approximativement correct
une troisième critique plus général et
le fait que le théorème fondamentale
repose sur le paradigme iiie des idées
ça veut dire indépendant est
identiquement distribué ça sous entend
notamment l'existence d'une loi de
probabilité fondamentale qui serait la
vraie loi de probabilité d'autres
cherchent des approximations alors dans
certains cas c'est une hypothèse qui est
très raisonnable mais bien souvent les
données sont corrélés et la loi de
probabilité qui les gouvernent si elles
existent peut varier en fonction de tout
plein de paramètres
en fait les trois critiques que je viens
de dresser la ne sont pas du tout
spécifique aux théories fondamentales
l'apprentissage statistiques
il s'agit d'une critique d'un formalisme
plus globale qui fait de nombreuses
hypothèses communément admise notamment
statistiques et que l'on appelle le
fréquentent isme et il y aurait
énormément à dire sur le fréquentent
isme sachant que c'est un petit peu
l'anti biyaïsme du côté obscur de la
force
mais je vais laisser ça de côté pour
aujourd'hui
une quatrième limite du torrent
fondamental c'est qu'il ne précise pas
comment choisir le chapeau à explication
alors que le choix de ce chapeau ce qui
revient à se poser la question du choix
de l'algorithme d'apprentissage est
précisément l'un des grands défis de la
recherche actuelle et en particulier
l'une des grandes questions de la
recherche actuelle c'est de déterminer
quelle est la bonne architecture de
réseaux de neurones artificiels
enfin une cinquième et dernière limite
du théorbe fondamental c'est qu'il
ignore toute notion de complexité
algorithmique
or de nos jours l'une des grandes
limitations du machine learning est le
fait que celui ci soit très gourmand en
calcul et en particulier il faut
absolument que nos algorithmes
d'apprentissage soit assez rapide
bref d'études théoriques du machine
learning comme vous commencez à le
comprendre c'est compliqué et en
particulier toute cette théorie semble
encore assez distante de ce que les
praticiens du machine learning font
vraiment en pratique
ceci étant dit le théories fondamentales
de l'apprentissage statistiques restent
très pertinent puisque il met le doigt
sur l'une des causes majeures de la
surinterprétation de façon grossière
si vous n'avez pas beaucoup moins de
paramètres dans vos modèles il n'ya de
données sur lesquelles vous pouvez vous
appuyer
vous devez absolument vous demander si
vous ne seriez pas en grave danger de
sur interprétations
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
avant de passer à vos réponses aux
commentaires une petite annonce puisque
je serai à lyon le lundi 26 mars en
soirée ou jeu donnera une présentation
sur les mathématiques de la démocratie
j'ai mis plus d'informations en
description de cette vidéo
les enfants n'a parlé des explications à
un dock et de la dimension wc et vous
êtes nombreux à voir ce qu'elle n'est
que c'était pas facile à comprendre
en effet alors entre eux sur des
concepts qui sont pas évidents j'ai
envie de dire que si vous n'avez pas
tout compris à la vidéo précédente c'est
pas grave je pense qu'on a un peu cette
idée à l'école que je sois absolument
tout comprendre quand on parle de
mathématiques mais bon il ya des
concepts qui sont difficiles en machine
learning
du coup bon bah c'est pas grave de ne
pas tout comprendre je pense que ce qui
était vraiment intéressant c'est un peu
l'idée intuitive que finalement plein
d'explications haddock france notamment
le fait que lorsqu'on sort une
explication et qui a une donnée que l'on
découvre qui va à l'encontre de cette
explication
n'attendant c'est à ce moment là à
sortir une explication haddock et bien
le fait de sortir de telles applications
haddock c'est une habitude à ne pas
prendre ou en tout cas une s'autoriser
qu'une fois toutes les 100 nouvelles
données quelque chose comme ça c'est un
petit peu cette idée globale qui est
envie de précédentes ainsi que ce
travail de formalisation pour passer de
l'intuition à quelque chose de
formaliser ladislas nal bord c'est que
nous fait remarquer que des notions
comme la dimension wc sont en fait
intimement lié à d'autres notions
utilisées en pratique comme par exemple
le critère d'information d'accueil
qu'est l'occasion pour moi de souligner
l'étendue de mon ignorance puisque je ne
connaissais pas ces critères mais il est
tout simple de ce critère c'est de
pénaliser le fait que un modèle est trop
complexe donc d'une part on veut qu il
explique bien les données donc ça c'est
le terme blog n qui s'appelait aussi à
l'ope vraisemblance et dont on parlera
mais pas aujourd'hui donc maximiser la
loque vraisemblance est quelque chose de
très classique en statistiques mais
pourra éviter d'avoir des modèles trop
complexe ce que propose à calquer ses de
pénaliser les modèles trop compliqué en
introduisant notamment une pénalité
égale au nombre de paramètres du modèle
dans les faits ça c'est une très bonne
idée et c'est en fait intimement liée à
un truc qu'on verra dans une future
vidéo qui s'appelle la régression de
l'assaut est ce également intimement
liée à des notions de base yanis monde
et notamment d'à priori bayésiens et
d'induction de solomonoff dans tous ces
cas ce qui est amusant c'est de voir que
dans ses modèles de machines downing
d'apprentissage statistiques qui sont
très mathématique a priori en fait on
voit surgir très naturellement
le concept de rasoir d'occam que l'on
appelle aussi le principe de parcimonie
qui dit que les modèles trop compliqué
en fait sont d'une certaine manière
mauvais parce qu'en fait ils conduisent
à la surinterprétation et du cou à des
modèles qui se généralise en fait très
mal accésss yeux et skippy l'un des
formats rich en fait il ya une
excellente vidéo sur youtube qui montre
très bien tout ce travail qu'il faut
faire pour rendre des jolies théorème
vrai et cette vidéo c'est une excellente
vidéo dj que je recommande vivement sur
le théorème de bisous qui apparemment
est le théorème préféré d'alj donc ça
vaut vraiment le coup
et c'est particulièrement intéressant de
voir comment un théorème faut peut être
rendue en un théorème vrai à condition
de le bidouiller un peu comme il faut
tout en essayant de coller encore à
l'intuition originale à tout ce travail
quelque chose que je trouve absolument
fascinant en fait j'ai quand même que
c'est ce que je préfère
en mathématiques voilà au fait remarquer
que être grammar nazis des notations
mathématiques en fait ça a du bon
puisque par exemple si on a une hauteur
et moi autant appeler à chelsea on n'a
rien on tourne appelé air tôt que
d'intervertir les notations quelques
on se retrouve vite avec des trucs qui
sont lisibles en tout cas pour les
mathématiciens entraîné en effet
utiliser les bonnes notations
c'est un peu comme utiliser le bon
langage les bons mots pour exprimer une
idée c'est quelque chose qui facilite
beaucoup la transmission de la
connaissance mais également le choix de
transmissions des intuitions la
réflexion également autour des idées ça
évite de s'embrouiller avec des détails
qui ne sont en fait que des détails ceci
étant dit comme le fait très bien
remarqué hydroxy chloride ceci a aussi
la mauvaise conséquence que des
étudiants qui ne sont entraînés qu'avec
un seul formalisme et qui ne sortent
jamais de ce formalisme peuvent être
complètement perdu dès que l'on change
un tout petit peu le formalisme dès
qu'on remplace par exemple des x ou y
j'avais un ami qui aimait d'hyères de
ses étudiants que faire une somme de 1
jusqu'à n essaye sa ferme et 2 1 jusqu'à
cas qu'ils sont complètement perdu et
c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut absolument
éviter dans l'apprentissage des
mathématiques
cette dépendance vraiment à la notation
et ça ça devient en fait
particulièrement pertinent quand on
regarde dans les recherches
interdisciplinaires puisque voilà les
physiciens ont tiré certaines notations
les mathématiciens de notation les
informaticiens d'autres notations encore
puis ça peut même varier à l'intérieur
d'une communauté peut être que les
cryptographes vont peut être y mène
notation que les chercheurs en machine
learning qui n'ont pas utilisé une
notation que chercher à enterrer la
complexité informatique
bref faut bien se rendre compte que les
notations qui on utilise pas c'est une
opération qui ont utilisé un moment
donné parce que c'est pratique pour nous
à ce moment là mais du coup il a de très
bonnes chances que d'autres personnes
utiliseront d'autres notation il faut
être capable de voir que des formules
écrite de manière différente sont en
fait équivalente
et pour cela je pense que c'est pas une
si mauvaise habitude que de raisonner
avec des symboles qui sont pas toujours
les mêmes et signent et d'être à l'aise
avec ces notations abstraite plutôt que
de s'enfermer dans ses propres notations
une certaine manière ça revient un petit
peu la différence entre apprendre et
comprendre
d'une certaine manière tant qu'on est
capable d'exprimer ses idées qu avec les
symboles que l'on a appris bien j'ai
envie de dire qu'on ne comprend pas
vraiment la nature des choses que l'on
manipule et j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va
parler mais quelque chose que je trouve
ultra important qui vraiment peut-être
le tout le plus important à savoir dans
toutes les statistiques et qui est très
peu enseignée et surtout très peu
compris des gens qui ont appris pourtant
les statistiques
par exemple le statisticien elle arriva
sur man 2 10 de ce que nous autres on va
parler
prochaine il sait qu'il s'agit de
quelque chose de très confondant oui je
sais que ce mode histoire mais j'ai eu
l'autorisation de me suffit de
l'utiliser dans un épisode actions y
compris pour des statisticiens bien
formés et pour illustrer ce dont on va
parler la semaine prochaine imaginez
l'exemple suivant supposons qu'il ya
deux joueurs de football qui voudraient
m'équipe et supposons que lorsque le
joueur
ajout son équipe gagne 80 % du temps et
supposons que lorsque le voir belge où
son équipe gagne 50% du temps est ce que
ça veut vraiment dire est ce qu'on peut
conclure que le joueur a et du coup
meilleur que le joueur b je vous invite
à réfléchir à cette question à vous
demander pourquoi est ce que cette
conclusion serait peut-être prématuré
oui parce que bien sûr il ya un petit
piège
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
la ligue et à le commenter à le partager
pense à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer
futurs épisodes merci aux ti peur pour
leurs dons et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois depuis huge de quality
of hope i pour celle à un peu de cette
date de 1916 m
which we shall kolda ouvert aux pénuries
m 10/06 bio marc beauvillain